Scot says what is your stance on net
neutrality given how the Internet has
become such an important part of how we
learn so I don't believe in net
neutrality I think I'd explained this a
few days ago on the show tonight I did a
whole segment on net neutrality I
thought where I discussed at length the
idea that ISPs
basically net neutrality is the
suggestion was only put into place in
the last couple of years of the Obama
administration and before that the
internet was working just fine net
neutrality is basically the suggestion
that internet service providers have to
supply traffic supply all use of traffic
the same price so Netflix which eats up
an enormous amount of bandwidth has to
be charged the same as some shmo in his
basement who is just loading up his blog
and it's also net neutrality also says
that all pages have to be loaded at the
same speed well the problem with that of
course is that it benefits big
corporations like Netflix over the
little guy the the reality is that if
you're taking up a huge share of the
bandwidth then you might there might be
companies that say you know we will
provide you a faster access but you have
to pay more money it's not incumbent on
Internet service providers to be forced
to be treated like public utilities the
way to think of it is that Internet
service providers are like the pipes and
the int and the content of the Internet
is like water so you can think of it in
two ways it's a public utility everybody
should be able to turn on the tap at the
same time and get the water or that the
pipe company should be able to charge
you what they want or charge the the
water company what it wants for the
water moving through the pipes the
reason it's not quite like a pipe is
because you can have multiple pipes
right there multiple internet service
providers one of the reasons that net
neutrality has become such an issue is
because of special deals with local
governments by a lot of the Internet
service providers so the only providers
in their region if there were open
competition you would actually see
competition like for people for example
who only use email but don't watch
streaming video right like older people
who only want to watch TV but don't
actually want to use Netflix or Hulu
they should be able to get the internet
cheaper then people who want to be able
to get Netflix and Hulu right or if you
only want to get Netflix and Hulu and
you don't use email right just these
text messages you should be able to have
these options there there's nothing
wrong with any of this
this is why when people say it's a
corporate giveaway and to get rid of net
neutrality there are major corporations
like Google and Netflix who basically
want to prevent smaller companies from
being able to take advantage of
differential pricing on ISPs to compete
with them so it
which corporations you're talking about
Google is a huge corporation Facebook's
a huge corporation Twitter is a huge
corporation all of them are in favor of
net neutrality because they are content
providers all the ISPs are in favor of
getting rid of net neutrality bottom
line is the internet was fine before
anybody started messing with it
net neutrality the the odd passion over
net neutrality is always puzzled me